hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds i'm a property investor and in
this video i'm going to be talking about
the pros and the cons versus buying
flats as investments apartments and just
straight houses and homes is it better
to buy flats or houses what gives you
the best return on investment and should
you consider flats when you're looking
to buy your first property investment so
here are my overall thoughts
there's no right or wrong answer i
personally prefer
houses and i'll tell you why in a moment
unless the flats are particularly unique
and
let me explain why so firstly the good
things about buying flats the reason
that people are attracted to buying
flats is that they're cheap so
you can buy flats in the midlands around
birmingham for like 30 40 50 000 pounds
and they are in decent areas they do
rent out okay and i think the fact that
they're so cheap really does attract
people to want to buy them secondly the
good thing about flats is it's really
easy to do your research on a flat
because especially if it's in like a
block
there's so many comparables so you can
see this one sold for 50 grand this one
sold for 55. this one sold for 53 and
you can look and you can see i'm right
with all the comparables so working out
whether you're getting a good deal and
working out what the rent is going to be
because there's so many like-for-like
comparables in that same block it makes
it really easy to do your research and
the third reason is because there's
really low maintenance so the garden's
communal if there's a garden at all
everything's all shared and communal the
building itself it's not your building
to have to maintain so you usually with
flats and i've got flats and i've also
got houses and there are um pretty low
maintenance the repairs and things i
tend to be quite low with flats so
that's the good
the bad so in my experience and i'm not
saying this is always the case because
it does depend on different factors but
i don't own loads of flats but the flats
that i did buy in 2009 2010 almost 10
years ago
haven't hardly appreciated in value at
all they've not gone up in value and i
think they did go up in value in the 90s
flats absolutely went crazy i think that
was partly because of the series and i'm
totally serious when i say this the
series friends
and they're all living and it's like a
cool lifestyle they're living in
apartments what happened in new york
everyone wanted to live in an apartment
and then um usually england copies and
follows america in some instances and
then suddenly it became really trendy
like in the 90s and everyone wanted to
live in an apartment but then when i
bought an apartment in 2009 i bought a
few
um
that's kind of died now everyone wants
houses and i've found in the last decade
apartments have become less and less
popular so the appreciation on them has
been very small compared to houses so
that's a bit of an egg and and to be
honest i can't see
i just can't see that flats are going to
rock it in value unless they're unique
and they're in a really good location or
they're they're um very special they're
penthouses or they're part of something
amazing i just can't see that they're
going to give the same capital
appreciation as houses will another
problem with flats is
i think if you wanted to sell a flat
people do not buy flats in 2019 to live
in what they do is they rent a flat
and then they save up and then they buy
a house so if you've got flats and
you're trying to sell them you're going
to struggle to sell them to
people that are going to actually live
in them homeowners you're going to sell
them to investors and if you're selling
them to investors investors never want
to pay the full price they want to get
squeezed the lowest so again wanting to
sell them afterwards unless you're
prepared to sell them quite low i think
you're going to struggle to sell them
but the biggest problem i have with
flats the number one reason i tell
people not to buy flats and to be
careful
is because of the service charge and
ground rent what does that mean because
you don't own the land because if you
just buy a flat in inside a building you
don't own the building you don't own the
land you're just buying
that apartment so what that means is
that means that you have to pay a
service charge and a ground rent to the
person who does own the land
and to keep everything like the communal
areas all okay and the scary thing about
flats is you cannot predict what that
service charge or ground rent might be
in the future so they can they can
change it sometimes it might just be a
couple hundred pound a year sometimes it
can be a couple thousand so if you are
gonna buy a flat just make sure that you
do your proper research and you know
exactly what your roi return on
investment is going to be and you've
included knocking off the ground rent
and the service charges so get that
information it's really important
because it can be a lot and it can you
can buy a flat and you can rent it out
for 600 pound a month and and once
you've paid your mortgage new management
you might be left with 300 pound a month
but if your service charge and ground
rank come down to 600 pounds a year
that's two months rent
totally wiped out just because it's a
flat and not a house so that's something
you really need to be careful of so i
think overall my advice would be
flats are okay
apartments that's the posh word for
staying flat they're okay but if you're
gonna buy one number one make sure that
you're aware that you probably aren't
gonna own the land
secondly be really careful on what the
ground rate and the service charge are
so you can work out your figures
properly and thirdly
make sure that it's not it's attractive
make sure that i mean make sure that
there's something special or something
unique so that when you go to want to
resell it you're gonna not have such a
hard time rather than just being like a
little tiny studio with 50 others the
same in a big block i'd be a bit careful
of those properties so i hope you found
that video useful my big suggestion if
you're going to go down flats i have to
say this is
if you buy the whole building and then
convert it into flats that's totally
different that's totally different
because then you own the land you've got
complete control and another good thing
about flats that you could do is you
could buy them and rent them out as
serviced accommodation so that could be
another reason where they where they
could be really profitable so it is gray
it's not black and white but i hope that
helps you when you're doing your
research
something i really suggest that you
check out is i've done a video called
what makes a good property investment
which just talks about all the things
you need to look for the basics when
you're before you buy any property
investment you can check that out
there's a video right here also if you
want to spend two days actually doing
this finding deals getting up your
laptops i'd really suggest that you come
down to the property investors crash
course on the house free on me you can
get tickets right here and don't forget
to subscribe over here as well